Hilary Clinton and Donald Trump just
might be the most unpopular presidential
candidates in US history and that's only
made this whole election year that much
more depressing but if you haven't
completely given up on voting for the
lesser of two evils you may be all the
more pissed to realize your vote may not
matter at all 126 million Americans
voted in the last presidential election
but the president was actually chosen by
just 538 people known as electors this
is the system at the heart of our
democracy the electoral college I like
to think of it as a compromise I checked
on dictatorial powers here's how it
works each state gets two electors plus
one for each of its congressional
districts so when you vote you're
actually picking a list of electors
nominated by each party who will then
pick a president and vice-president on
behalf of your state this sounds pretty
undemocratic I mean who are these people
and why do they get to decide I went to
Atlanta to talk to one of them this is
about keu the son of Vietnamese
immigrants and a Republican activist
from Georgia chosen to be one of the
party's electors it was a very big and
humbling honor for me to be nominated as
an elector I find it odd that the
American people whether they know or not
that it's the electors who choose the
president they don't even know who you
are in old days the nominees for
electors would actually be on the ballot
so what we've gotten through is actually
this process where we've D formalize the
electoral college process and that's
almost an understatement as public
historian Jason Steinhauer explains the
Electoral College was designed for a
very different political reality
originally the way it was set up is that
the states would choose the electors the
electors would choose the president
right that was before political parties
so that's another important contextual
issue to think about when thinking about
the electoral college
political parties didn't exist in 1787
but today the electors are largely
chosen by the political parties sound
like a conflict of interest when you go
to vote you actually are voting for a
party so a few Georgians vote for Trump
what you're actually doing is voting for
Balki to then choose who he thinks
should be president except with his
party's candidate being this guy he just
couldn't bring himself to do it I got up
at 4:00 a.m. and I thought you know
I've seen enough of this this was a
process of many decisions points with
the last straw being the attacks on the
Khan family so why did you resign that
was become a distraction for the state
party here there's a lot of pressure on
electors to vote according to what the
party wants that's not quite how the
Founding Fathers wanted the Electoral
College to work it still seems
unamerican that the Electoral College is
enshrined in our Constitution but
there's absolutely no mention of the
popular people may think it's an
American and yet it is supremely
American but that doesn't mean things
can't change in our system of government
is important for citizens to be informed
it's important for citizens to ask
questions to make sure that we're
getting the government that we deserve
and so it's perfectly fair to ask if the
collector old college still serves the
best purpose